have you ever struggled with the
pronunciation of a foreign language
learning the pronunciation of any
foreign language for that matter is a
little bit challenging a little bit
tricky for a number of reasons but there
are some languages which are
particularly difficult to pronounce
depending on your mother tongue for
example it's really difficult for a
native English speaker to pronounce
languages such as French or Russian or
Arabic and for the rest of the world
English the very same language I am
speaking right now is quite difficult to
pronounce hi my name is Luca from Luca
vampire comm and today I'm going to talk
to you about how to tackle and how to
learn the pronunciation of any language
and in particular of difficult languages
a few months ago I decided to learn a
beautiful Scandinavian language Danish
now if you've never heard Danish Danish
sounds like this just give me the insane
food you get me oh this could be
handsome
yeah that's right it sounds like they
have a big potato in their mouth and
that's what actually other Scandinavians
and other people say about them in
general every language that you learn
will have a different inventory phonetic
inventory that is the amount of sounds
that are contained in the language and
this inventory is different from your
inventory the inventory of your own
native language that's why it is
difficult to acquire the pronunciation
of any other language but there is a key
point to take into account 10 or maybe a
little bit more than 10 years ago I
started learning swedish and like every
other language I just like God in the
language I was listening I was reading I
was doing a lot of things I was exposing
myself to the language and then I made a
youtube video my first youtube video
where I also spoke Swedish and I got you
know some feedback about my
pronunciation and intonation and it
turned out both turned out to be off and
I started asking myself what's wrong
what did I do wrong
well I neglected the fact that Swedish
is a see my tonal language and has pitch
accent so that's a very peculiar feature
of Swedish just to give you an idea you
can have a word that can be pronounced
in two completely different ways for
example you can say on then which means
duck or on then which means spirit and I
had completely overlooked this aspect of
the language as a consequence of that I
developed wrong fanatic patterns and a
few years down the line I just figured
out that my patterns were actually wrong
now if you figured that out that's great
but the problem is that figuring it out
and make it
happen that is fixing or reducing your
accent as someone says is quite
difficult to do
imagine a knot the tighter the knot is
and the better it is
if this knot is tied well but if the
knot is tied wrong and you have to untie
it that's quite a lot of work to do and
most of the time of the game is actually
not worth a candle okay
now you know that you have to start
head-on you have to start from the very
beginning and take care of your
pronunciation and your intonation but in
any language there are some sounds which
are particularly difficult to pronounce
for example the French uh-huh or the
Italian Spanish yeah or the Iying I
cannot pronounce that I don't speak
Arabic but you get the idea and in
Danish you have the infamous soft D for
example when I was in Paris I met a
Danish girl who had me try actually
pronounce a whole call Malou I still
don't pronounce it well maybe a little
bit better and I could not by looking at
her face I could not tell what kind of
sound that was how you could produce it
and when I started learning Danish I
tried my best at looking at some
explanations how do you put your mouth
and I was reading instructions and here
and there and I was hearing the sound
and I was trying to reproduce it until I
stumbled upon a video in this video this
Danish guy makes the case that in order
to pronounce the soft D you have to
start from a given position of your
mouth that you already used in your own
native language and move from there so
just to give an example what he did is
he said you can watch the video by
clicking on the link and the description
box what he does is very simple he says
in order to say oh look the soft D which
actually sounds a little bit like an L
try to start from
the position of the L in your mouth so
if you see L you will see that try
yourself now you will see that your
tongue goes up touches the palate look
this is the way you pronounce L in
English let an Italian slightly
different but the concept is exactly the
same so we have a tendency in our own
native language if your native language
is English or even Spanish or Italian to
pronounce the L by putting the tongue on
an our palate but in Danish that doesn't
happen you have to put VL you have to
keep your tongue down and it's difficult
so at the beginning when I was trying to
say 'la the Consul Amy came up when you
went up the roof of my mouth look look
look and then I told myself you know how
do you how do you sold how do you solve
this and then the guy happened so he
said take two fingers and put the
fingers on your tongue so you keep it
down so uh-huh
this way I know it could be disgusting
but look the hole hole a hole coal so
you try and then you try a few times and
then it actually it happens it it causes
your mind or and your muscle memory to
get accustomed to this new configuration
and then you all you have to do is to
keep going and then you don't need these
fingers anymore so like I started like
this whole whole the whole difficult to
pronounce because I have two fingers in
my mouth but then they started saying it
and I started liking saying it for
example in Danish you say already you
say Allah Allah Allah so whole called
with flu al availa and truth be told I
am sure that I still do not pronounce it
correctly but it was a huge improvement
and I was quite frustrated at the
beginning this goes to show that if you
put your mind to it if you know how to
learn sounds if you use a combination of
channels which is all your channel
visual explanations but also you learn
how to lever
the positions of your mouth when it
comes to producing sounds in your own
language in order to produce other
sounds you can accomplish anything you
just need to know where to start from
and how
learning to pronounce to actually
produce and articulate sounds in your
mouth is fantastic you can be
contraindicated happens when you
actually start producing sentences
because the truth is that we communicate
through messages that are coded in
sentences so when you learn the
pronunciation of a foreign language and
make sure that after some training with
single sounds you take care of how you
pronounce an utter entire sentences and
the example of the soft D when I started
doing is I started saying very short
sentences that chain words that contain
D and I kept saying them over and over
this allowed me to learn the
articulation of the Softee but at the
same time learn the intonation in
sentences remember that we communicate
in messages these messages are coded in
chunks and learning in chunks is much
faster and more efficient than learning
the single components of the language
okay this is the end of the video
unfortunately but here is the wrap-up
first make sure that you tackle
pronunciation and intonation the
phonetic fabric of a language head on
from the very beginning to get patterns
right because if you do that your life
will get much easier down the line
second make sure that when it comes to
particularly difficult sounds to
pronounce you actually train and you try
to figure out how to pronounce these
languages not just by sound not just by
hearing not just by looking and
explanations but also to see visually
how people pronounce how native
pronounce e sounds and whether it's
possible just to move from a position of
your mouth that you already know and you
already used in your native language or
a language you speak and third make sure
that you move from training on single
sounds to training on short fragments or
sentences or phrases and you can kill
the proverbial two birds with one stone
now I got a challenge for you and some
more info about this topic if you have a
camera and if you have a good microphone
and make a video of yourself trying to
train on a specific sound and trying to
say a few fragments or a few phrases a
few sentences using that sound so you
have a camera make a video of yourself
training on a specific sound that you
find difficult and remember to train not
only on single words that contain the
sound but also on short sentences and if
you want to know more please click on
the link in the description box I have
written a very extensive article about
this very same topic that you can read
and listen to and of course drop a bunch
of comments in the comment section below
thank you very much and see you soon on
YouTube
[Music]